Right off the bat, let's remember what slope-intercept form is. You've probably
got it but it never hurts to write it down one more time. We want to get this
equation in the form y with an coefficient of 1, or course, equals mx plus b.
The first thing we need to do then is to get our term with y to be the only term
on the left side of the equation. So we need to subtract 12x from both sides.
Then, to get the coefficient of y to be 1, you just divide both sides by 5.
Then, if you're picky like me and you want the equation to be exactly in this
form, we just rearrange the order of our two terms on the right-hand side. We're
allowed to do this because of commutativity and we end up with y equals negative
12 5ths x plus 7 5ths. This is great. Now we can see right away that the slope
is negative 12 over 5. And the y coordinate of the y intercept is 7 over 5.